hello the common dust games come i'm
here with Peter bran hang on my friend
good it's been a long week but it's been
a fun one it has and you chopped it off
with it with a game is coming out very
soon it's coming at a couple of weeks
time same days metal gear solid 5 tell
me all about razy mad max we're mad max
right we all probably most of us saw the
film and loved it and more a lot more of
that you're gonna get some of the stuff
that was from the film but this game
isn't even based on the film it's based
on the Mad Max property so you've got
max you're set in the wasteland you've
got a vehicle but it's not the
Interceptor it is the magnum opus it's a
car that you spend lots of time like you
know customizing and gets your you know
you your work of the thing that you
spend a lot of time doing and
essentially what you're trying to do is
you know survive in the wasteland and
sort of defend yourself from these
different factions that are out there to
get you and there are two really big
components to the game there is a sort
of the exploration stuff that you do on
foot within like small missions and
strongholds that has combat very similar
to the Batman series and then you have
the you know the driving stuff and the
driving combat which what do you want to
know I don't know I did a little bit of
the driving stuff myself I only got like
five or ten minutes on it was kind of
felt like a little bit like Mordor in a
way where there's a kind of a big map
wasn't too big but I had this car and I
was kind of looking at different parts
in the mapping up and seeing what was
there and it was like a sniper tower
which was cooler than a car that I
crashed into and had been a combat with
that what was your experience of playing
the car stuff so what I did is I use the
car to go towards a waypoint which is
where a mission was going to take place
and you know the driving feels pretty
good you can fire weapons from the car
either as max where you have like a
shotgun or your little buddy chum bucket
in the back can use a harpoon or a
rocket launcher to help you tear things
down or blow them up and I thought there
was a lot of potential to it and I still
think there might be but the demo that I
played was very limited because I got to
the stronghold and they wanted me to
sort of take apart these vehicles and
blow them up I was driving in really
tight quarters when you aim holding
l1 button on the PlayStation controller
time slows down and you have these
little reticles that you can then put
your reticle over and hit circle to act
upon it but the camera moves a lot and
when you get finished firing your camera
firing your weapon the camera doesn't
always go back to where you want it so I
actually found myself a little bit
flustered trying to navigate through
this small but populated environment
after firing my weapons and what was it
like on foot then presumably the camera
issues weren't as exaggerated in the
game reissues weren't really a problem
at that point I mean you're you don't
really have a whole lot to do like
you're running around you sort of engage
with calm in combat but you don't have
things like the harpoon you don't have
the rocket launcher so you don't have
this sort of set of fantastical tools to
use you basically got a shotgun you've
got a knife and you've got your fists
the combat is almost identical to the
Batman series and for me personally it
is a very simplified system that's not
very fun right I don't feel like I'm
really doing anything with my own
creativity like as a combatant you sort
of just you be a tap square you see an
icon you press triangle it's it's kind
of rudimentary so I'm not really excited
about that part come on and there's
another game very similar to this just
cause 3 and the sort of coming out this
year and it's sort of way that you are
going to be a single character in a
large world with a checklist of stuff to
do and what do you buy the same studio
it is in fact made by the same studio it
kind of reminds me with like I said
Mordor but also like far cry where
you've got like outpost but then you've
got random things that happen and you're
exploring did you there's not the type
of game that it is is it just like a
checklist of things to do I mean it's
open world you can just run around and
do a bunch of stuff or you find
waypoints and I believe there is a story
that has beats to it that then send you
do specific locations you know I think
what my biggest concern is is that you
know the most potential for Mad Max lies
in the car stop yeah and I haven't
really seen how that's being put to use
you know in the movie it was so great
because you had used he's drawn out
chases right where you know people they
catch up to max and maybe he blows them
up it keeps going and he comes up on
something else and has to change his
tactics uh I don't know how the car is
going to be used in that regard like if
there will be pretty big chases I really
hope so because I think that really
isn't much
interesting aspect just causing their
hand is like this big like fantastical
thing with these incredible tools that
are so over the top and exciting right
now if I to choose between the two I
would absolutely choose just cause ya
all right well I guess we'll hear more
about my max over the coming weeks yeah
before comes a thanks very much Peter
it's more information on Mad Max well
and everything happening here in
beautiful Cologne Germany stay tuned to
gamespot com
you